I eat [__] though I bet you can yeah
yeah yeah you know your people can cook
some
fish I also do theatrics in there you
know well you know most people I tell
you white man created eating vagina you
think so yeah black men didn't start
that [__] to the late 90s early 90s late
90s because they didn't need to they
don't have to a lot yeah yeah are they
good at it the ones I've had was pretty
good I've never had an Asian I mean a
Korean so I don't know what y'all do
that's what I'm saying you've never
dated a Karan I never dated outside my
race Bobby Le you never dated a white
guy no why because white men don't like
fat women they give their fat women to
black
men duh dude
duh they kill him that too man history
dude yeah you don't watch [__] I said
lose weight and H head with a
brick white men is only like fat women
if if the cup is extremely
poor but white people with money they
don't want to know out of shape white
[__] yeah yeah holy [__] dude but what
I'm saying right now because if like I
know you're married yeah a long time
long time but if you were single and I I
don't know if I could date outside my
race yeah but but listen you're
successful one of the funniest people on
planet Earth I'm pretty sure if you
wanted that you could get the white dick
I could get the white dick but and
there's no curiosity what if it tastes
like different than black dick first of
all I'm I'm 51 years old I'm not sucking
no dick cuz I got
vertigo and I have some I I don't have
that's a young girl sport I have really
bad TMJ too so what is TMJ it's that
pain in the jaw like right in this joint
here when you suck penises when I even
when I'm chewing or even like right now
it hurts that's why I can't wear over
the ear cans either so sucking dick is
like an Olympic sport it just it's too
much
effort you left Bobby Lee the easiest
[__] metal you could have
got well that's why we were together for
10 years it was he didn't [__] up your
TMJ didn't [__] up my TMJ this big
Hawaiian is knocking your
brain oh my God you probably sucking
dick and eating her
bread so so so what you're saying to me
Pat Miss P cuz I you know I'm seeing a
young lady right now
okay and um what what what nationality
she's half Korean she what and half
white oh she got a Kano Reeves kind of a
Vibe of woman you know you got a [__]
look like Keo ree but like that kind of
no that kind of Asian that's mixed you K
reev has a little bit of [__] Asian
in them you dating
Ellen Ellen generous yeah no she has no
Asian in her oh
what what you describing to me is a l
lesbian right he say she look like ke re
a goddamn
man you you that's sort of mixture you
last anyway let's go how you going to
date K re after having it I I don't
forget it forget the [__] forget the
analogy okay I can't breathe okay yeah I
can't breath it so I'm dating a woman
and I swear to God she said to me she
goes you know what I think your penis is
perfect and I said
we I forgot to put the L's in there you
know me that was so [__] confused I
go really you should have said [__] how
old are
you she's 32 and she goes it's just the
right perfect size your speed the smell
of it everything is perfect and I and I
I took her for her
word so you think she's lying to me yes
I I'm going tell you um yeah
um no dick is a perfect size it's the
money and and then you know is she thick
is she really small she's I don't do
thick I do she's petite like half my
size so she probably got you sticking
her dick in her navor or somewhere else
that's why it's a perfect size because
first of all she's petique so we already
know she got a long [__] cuz real
skinny people got a longone [__] her
[__] probably go up her bag so which
[__] are you SK
the the back end back the back wait that
is a really good point yeah cuz and you
say she's Asian right half half asian
everybody know Asians got long [__]
that's what they used to say back in the
day I I don't know but never heard that
have you heard that before never heard
that
before that's what black people are
saying behind their backs the asan got
really long [__] yeah yeah yeah we so
wow wow wow you pink for vaginas huh I
got Pig for a vagina no no no no no pink
I don't [__] know what color my
vagina is I se I've seen the porn and
black porn I and if you look inside the
vagina all [__] is pink on the ins got
I'm giving you a compliment what what
what do our [__] supp be black cuz we
black our [__] pink and she white she's
half asian I don't give a [__]
okay okay I'm just oh [__] that's one
place we all we all look alike it all
[__] look alike okay good we got that
point and we can move we can move on
from it but you're saying she she says
you're perfect so this girl says I'm
perfect she literally looked at me
legitimately and she's not an actress
what in the little Bey eyes that I have
the black dots that I have and she goes
um no honestly like that was it's the
best like I love it and so you know I
just take her for a word and I I believe
and I believe her and but but when
you're talking though right now it makes
me feel like she was
lying
you know goddamn
where I'm your good friend a lying Ain't
Nobody Got no perfect dick she for what
I seen in your pants that's a um your
tip it's some money are you are you
buying her nice bags and shoes and
taking her out well I take I'm took her
to different country like places island
of course Bobby Lee your dick is
perfect what a first class fight you
goddamn right
your oh my God take me to a different
country I'm going tell everybody you got
a perfect dck you're right he [__] me
in my
ears you're right you're right we can
move on let's move on I don't want to
talk about my pis anymore yeah he's
anyway and let you know and and God
bless your for China let's move on from
it I'm sure it's great but you know what
I got to say this we move on and I love
you B I love you thank you for having me
on here but if you was gay You' have
been perfect cuz you wouldn't had
nothing to tape
down